so i thought i'd reintroduce our old
friend to the bag of sugar
so one of the comments on that we made a
video about masses and things and
weights one of the comments asked what
the on the next to one kilogram what the
little e means which i didn't actually
know so i went and looked it up and it
turns out it just means that the mass is
estimated which kind of makes sense
right because actually a bag of sugar is
never going to be exactly a kilogram
because you know well this one's got a
leak apart from anything else so the odd
grain is going to get out but you never
define things to be you know exactly one
kilogram so which got me to thinking
about what actually defines a kilogram
and it's a bit timely too because it
seems likely that the definition of a
kilogram is actually about to disappear
not just to change but to disappear
entirely the kilogram will no longer be
defined there is currently a piece of
precious metal which was made in london
but it's stored in paris in a vault in a
vacuum and it's never looked aw it's
looked at a few times a year i think and
very rarely taken out which is the
official definition of the kilogram
which is sort of a bit of an anachronism
in that so
i guess we need to do a little bit of
history we back up to the beginning the
si unit was defined and it was actually
defined
the meter for example was defined to be
1 10 millionth the distance from the
north pole to the equator going through
paris so you can tell who invented this
particular system of units okay that was
the original definition of the meter and
then everything kind of flowed from that
in that a liter of water was defined to
be a tenth of a meter by a tenth of a
meter by a tenth of a meter and if you
then took a liter of water at four
degrees centigrade and distilled water
and so on that was the definition of a
kilogram and so the definitions all kind
of flow from that and then you needed a
second as well but that's sort of
defined in terms of astronomy things the
calendar the length of the year and so
on so that gives you a second those were
the original definitions but it's not
very practical in that if you actually
want to measure a meter it's not very
handy to have to measure the distance
from the north pole to the equator
through paris every time you want to
figure out how long a meter is and so
quite quickly the definition of the
official definition of the meter changed
from being that to being the length of a
particular rod also stored in a vault in
paris and the definition of the kilogram
was defined to be a particular mass that
was stored in the vault in paris i mean
again that although that's a kind of now
and a clear definition it's not very
helpful because it you then have to go
to a vault in paris every time you want
to know what a kilogram is as obviously
that you know they deal with that for
example the kilogram they made lots of
copies of it the copies got sent around
the world but one of the things they
found is that they don't all stay the
same mass so one of the things they do
when they compare these kilogram
standard masses against each other they
find that actually they don't all have
the same mass anymore and in particular
the one that's stored in the vault in
paris has lost mass relative to the ones
that are stored elsewhere
or probably more likely the ones that
are stored elsewhere have actually
gained mass because actually they're
handled more and they're more in the air
and so on so atoms stick to them and
bits of you know muck stick to them and
so on so over time they'll drift in and
that's not it's not a helpful way of
having your units defined so actually
you need something kind of more
fundamental the meter the official meter
is no longer that rod that disappeared
some considerable time again now the
official meter is defined in terms of
distance that light travels in one 299
million 792
458 of a second
okay is the official definition of the
meter
um and that's where we are with that and
that's more fundamental and more helpful
because actually that's in terms of a
fundamental physical constant that's in
terms of the speed of light
and so for example if we were to
discover life on alpha centauri and we
wanted to kind of send messages to them
about things we'd measured we could
actually explain to them what a meter
was in terms of something that they
could measure which you couldn't do if
it was just a length of a ruler and a
bank vault somewhere
um but the kilogram at the moment we're
still stuck with this weight
um in the bank vault and so actually you
can't explain to somebody over the phone
what a kilogram is or you know
by radio telescope or whatever it is you
can't explain what what a kilogram
actually is and so partly motivated by
the fact that it's sort of hard to
reproduce and partly motivated by making
it sort of a bit more fundamental
there's a move to change the definitions
of all the fundamental units
in so that instead of defining our units
in terms of things we define them in
terms of the fundamental constants
and then so then at the moment for
example planck's constant for example is
measured you know we define our units
and then we make some careful experiment
using those units and then we can say
what our measured value of planck's
concert is but but an alternative way of
defining the units is doing it the other
way around you define the value of
planck's constant
and then that in turn will then define
the units that come from from there
so there's a mover for in the next few
years to change these definitions
how the kilograms going to be done
there's still i believe there's still
some competition there's either going to
be some exact number of silicon atoms
there's one way of doing it but i think
the front runner now is actually you
throw out the kilogram entirely as a
fundamental unit and your units then
become things like plant's constant the
speed of light boltzmann's constant and
those kinds of things and from those it
turns out you can construct what a
kilogram has to be i mean in terms of
its value
it would still be almost exactly the
same in fact it would by definition
because you define it you know you take
the at the moment we define the kilogram
we measure the
constants of nature as best we possibly
can and we get values for them what they
would do is they would take those values
they would then be defined
as you know planck's constant would be
exactly equal to this
rather than it's measured to be this
plus or minus a little bit and then from
that you could then figure out what a
kilogram was and of course because we're
using the same numbers you'd actually
end up with a kilogram which is kind of
indistinguishable from you know the
kilograms that we have today the issue
here is is how do you actually do this
right and so there are
there are a number of fundamental
quantities that get defined and so just
this is just to show you that you can
actually when you define these
fundamental quantities you can put them
together to figure out what a kilogram
has to be one of the quantities that
gets defined you need something to
define time with and you actually define
a frequency mu0 and this is the
frequency of radio waves given out by a
particular atom in a particular
transition so it's a
it's not in some sense a fundamental
constant of nature but it's something
that any anyone would agree anywhere in
the world or in the universe if they
took the relevant atoms of cesium
and made this measurement of this
particular frequency it would oscillate
nine billion times a second or
thereabouts and that would give you a
frequency measurement which you can
clearly then defer to turn into a time
right it's doing this many times per
second so if we just wait till it's done
it's nine billion oscillations that's
one second that's how atomic clocks work
isn't it it is how atomic clocks work
and it's very stable way of doing things
okay so that's that's one of the the new
definitions the second possible thing
that we would define is planck's
constant which is to do with the the
quanta of nature and one of the third
thing we might want to define is the
speed of light so as i say at the moment
both these things are just measured as
indeed is this frequency but we could
actually just define them and now we can
start putting things together so we have
a cesium atom it goes through this
transition it emits a photon of light
with that frequency then we can figure
out the energy of that photon it's just
equal to planck's constant times the
frequency of the
photon being emitted okay that's just
planck's law for figuring out the energy
of a photon when you know its frequency
so that's now an energy
and you might imagine again this is just
not an experiment that anyone would ever
do in practice but you might imagine
okay so let's take that energy and turn
it into a mass and again we'll use one
of the other very famous equations
of physics which is this is the energy
we've got to play with and we can turn
that into a mass through einstein's
famous equation e equals m c squared
okay and so now we know what the mass we
would turn that photon into its mass
would just be equal to
we went in this equation planck's
constant which is now just defined to be
something
times this frequency which we've defined
divided by the speed of light squared
which is defined
so that means that the mass we will get
out of this
entirely impractical experiment is
completely defined in terms of the
quantities that we've already defined
and then we just say okay so if we take
however many trillion of those little
masses we could stick them together to
make a kilogram and there's no freedom
there anymore the the mass of the
kilogram is completely defined in terms
of these fundamental quantities of
nature you're talking as though planck's
constant and the speed of light and
these other fundamental constants
we don't quite know what they are no
so if later on we find we got them a bit
wrong but we won't find we got them a
bit wrong because we've defined them to
be these particular values and all that
would happen
is then the length of the meter would
change by a tiny tiny fraction or the
mass of a kilogram would tame change by
a tiny tiny fraction because they are no
longer defined quantities so if it's
some clever more clever experiment
relating the length of a ruler to
planck's constant comes along later on
we won't show in the past what would
have happened is we'd have changed
planck's constant so we've got the
measurement of planck's constant a
little bit wrong
now we'll just say oh we got the
definition of the meter a little bit
wrong and we'll change the meter by a
tiny fraction but planck's constant the
speed of light they're exactly equal to
those quantities and all that will
happen if the some subsequent
measurement changes is that that will
change the length of the meter or the
kilogram i mean it's you know for
everyday purposes it really doesn't
matter because these quantities are
sufficiently well known that any
subsequent measurements are only going
to change things by the tiniest of
amounts but they are more fundamental
constants of nature so it's nice to have
them not changing and change the length
of the meter or the mass of the kilogram
instead because they are in some sense
less fundamental
it
yeah but the you know the trouble with
the romance is it sometimes gets in the
way of science and i think this is one
of those cases where yes having that
romantic definition is is unhelpful to
the scientists